pour toutes les familles qui possèdent
un ordinateur le danger vient parfois
d'internet images violent pornographique
ou prise de contact non surveillée sur
les tchats jusqu alors les parents
devaient faire la démarche de demander
un contrôle parental
à partir de 2006 ce sont les
fournisseurs d'accès qui devront
systématiquement le proposer
gratuitement valérie fournier jean
françois roth il se promène sur internet
de plus en plus jeune abby les curieux
les sites dangereux sont à leur portée
dès 2006 une offre de contrôle parental
sera proposé systématiquement par les
fournisseurs d'accès de quoi aider les
parents à assumer leurs responsabilités
très bien dans cette dans ce projet
c'est que on leur donne les outils pour
exercer leurs responsabilités
il ya rien de pire que de dire à des
personnes vous devez être responsable
mais qu'on ne leur donne pas les outils
leur permettant de lettres et il existe
déjà de nombreux outils des logiciels
gratuits plus ou moins fiables que vous
pouvez télécharger sur internet puis
installez sur votre disque dur
les réglages sont aisés vous décidé
l'interdiction des sites sexuellement
explicites violents ou racistes et d'un
simple clic l'ordinateur blog pour vous
mais pour plus de sécurité vous pouvez
compléter votre abonnement un
fournisseur d'accès qui propose un
contrôle parental pour l'instant payant
avec mise à jour régulière aujourd'hui
tous les fournisseurs d'accès s'engage à
proposer clairement ce service il n'y a
pas juste les capacités de filtrage
qu'il faut juger
il ya aussi à quel point il est
difficile ou non de désactiver cet outil
à quel point cet outil permet en plus de
la protection par rapport au contenu de
protéger les enfants contre des
communications non désirées et ses accès
le système actuel est surtout valable
pour les tout petits les parents très
doué aujourd'hui 31 % d'entre eux ne
connaissent pas les systèmes de
protection et parmi ceux qui sont
avertis un quart seulement les utilisent
la meilleure des protections reste la
présence des parents une présence non
virtuel fait de dialogue et
d'explication des risques et les à
quelques heures tout